bonjour berra alors qu'est ce que l'on
doit retenir du discours de vladimir
poutine
bonjour à meerab elle la récession
économique on est actuellement dû à la
pandémie djokovic 19 est la plus
importante depuis et la seconde guerre
mondiale a déclaré le président russe a
dit merckx thing il a également pointé
du doigt le problème de la disponibilité
des vaccins est également expliquer le
retard de l'approbation du vaccin aux
russes je vous propose d'écouter
il y a des intérêts concrets de la part
de ceux qui mènent cette activité ils
assurent leur marché avec les structures
avec lesquelles il travaille depuis
longtemps et donc un système jeux
d'intérêts croisés qui est bien
structuré bien entendu la politique
existe toujours un degré ou un autre
mais ici il s'agit clairement d'intérêt
économique aux dépens de la santé des
citoyens européens
la grosse déclaration d'aujourd'hui
c'est évidemment la noce de vladimir
poutine de de la fin des constructions
de la première ligne du gazoduc nord
stream 2 qui relie la russie avec l
allemagne vladimir poutine a même
déclaré que la société russe gazprom
était prête à fournir le gaz très
bientôt
je vous propose d'écouter
ça a été la la pose du gazoduc nord
stream 2 vient d'être achevée et
pourquoi je dis ça parce que c'est de le
système le plus le plus avancé du point
de vue technologique et cet itinéraire
va relier le système le système national
en russie et l'allemagne
donc tout cela fait en sorte que nous
avons des approvisionnements sûrs
fiables vers l'europe
la lumière poutine a ainsi abordé le
sommet avec son homologue américain joe
biden qui aura lieu le 5 juin prochain
je vous propose d'écouter
nous allons parler de questions de
bilatérales je partirai type outils du
principe de chercher un mode de
règlement de ces relations qui sont
particulièrement tendues aujourd'hui
tout le monde le sait nous allons parler
de la stabilité stratégique du règlement
des conflits à l'international sur les
points les plus chauds du globe
nous allons parler des processus de
désarmement de lutte contre le
terrorisme de la pandémie de la lutte
contre la pandémie
je n'ose en parler aussi de questions
d'ordre et que j'ai c'est en gros
l'agenda qui est prévu la session
plénière cette année a duré presque
trois heures ils ont également participé
à vis de conférence le chancelier
autrichien céda 5 août et l'émir du
qatar tamim bin hamad al thani
merci à vera pour